hello and welcome to this video playing
senior now pause okay let's go here and
see what he's up to senior novel them
play before right now let's play
something unconventional with 96 and
it's not very commonly seen it's not
such a bad move
yeah okay he knows something yes okay a
three that is one of the best moves now
preventing Bishop before and now black
is switching to a King's Indian set up
later with e5 interesting to see that we
get this preparing e5 him rook e8 is
looking strange but it has an idea the
idea is that after e5 d5 I have the move
Knight to d4 so I'm not going to go back
with the night and be rather passive
only seven but jump right into the
center so that the knight will very
likely get traded rainy looks weird why
would you allow that
okay what do we do yeah I think I take
with the bishop I mean Knight takes is
also attractive but this is it looks
decidedly wrong but white is doing I
really get close to the king quickly
let's not move too quickly here because
I also have Knight F form threatening
mate yeah but that is actually not that
helpful this looks fine and don't want
to trade
oh it's Queen h4 stronger
Queen h4 might be stronger because he
doesn't have King age 1 as a reply now
then I can take twice on g3 and then
because of this pin then and yeah yeah
my threat now is when it's my threat I'm
threatening to sacrifice on g3 right 93
pawn takes Bishop takes pawn takes Queen
takes check King edge one rookie five
and over no that is a threat how is he
replying to this idea it's not quite
clear maybe he has to go rook e1 to
avoid this immediate disaster that also
prepares Bishop f1 yeah that is the best
move that's the best move
okay now
yeah with Bishop f1 his is patching and
some of those holes
if I now sacrifice he is King f1 at the
end
I wonder if f5 is an idea it doesn't
feel entirely convincing hmm I don't
feel I have the right approach here I
mean I'm quite obviously in good shape
after move like this but I had this
feeling I should should have more but
didn't go didn't quite see Adam okay um
how do we continue to attack
I probably yeah let's let's do this
bring the H point into play I mean I
don't have to win by checkmate yeah
necessarily on the King I just have
strategically advantageous position with
those great pieces and White has no
players she just has no play just one
Kim I come back here and then then age
is probably not bad
h4 is going to go Knight to e2 let's do
it
I can simply take and and play Queen f4
I mean that is that is quite simple took
me a long time to see this simple idea
let's not pre move that silly I don't
think it has a move that would make
wiener form bad but still yeah that is
actually two completely killing No yeah
that was a um yeah allowing this Bishop
g4 was really a bit odd yeah in this
position um White has to handle this
idea with with 94 it's not so easy
actually even here I have e5d 594 it's
not a huge issue because me I just get a
trade yeah and it's not bad for might
and it's important to see that this
leads to absolutely nothing here black
equalizes very comfortably you know I
get to trade pieces and in general this
Bishop doesn't look great in such a
structure so it looks at those pawns and
we had a something quite similar here
and I think you should just play we
should be three and this is okay alright
I don't think it's very scary I think
the scarier lines are happening earlier
once once I'm around here I'm okay
yeah Bishop e3 and now I would probably
take somewhere a five is interesting
that's actually very interesting in this
particular situation because I'm
threatening to take here and take on
one if white has to play b5 I have
accomplished something
yeah it looks comfortable maybe before
it's not so much to the point why he has
to take on e5 here we're just always
possible okay
he went Bishop d3 and now after Bishop
g4 I'm already better
you should play Bishop e2 M I mean it
looks it's not what you want to do but
it's what you have to do it's just
basically saying okay my last move was
stupid but they have to do it
okay now this ship takes Knight h5 it
took it I think it's best to just
recapture as I did 92 Bishop b5 93 and
now Queen h4 with hindsight maybe Queen
h4 isn't the best move actually when we
I mean he had this rook e1 and it looks
like he's continuing this and he does
that it looks like he defends for the
moment it's what I'm trying to say
h5 I didn't see how how quickly this is
going downhill yeah he has no he has
just no way to prevent this actually you
know Queen see one maybe said a move
h4 92 and then I've got this of course
you know yeah it is just to only winning
yam and queen FY took me took me a while
to see that but it just totally or if
why do we captures I know like this and
it's just just mate yeah okay guys
thanks for watching